big visible program in Baltimore called
the shoemaker-levy 9 comet crash into
Jupiter it was a big deal I was on the
nightly news every night for a week and
my local high school in Pennsylvania
sent a TV crew down to Baltimore to
interview me and they asked me what was
the most important class you took in
high school to prepare you to become a
world-famous scientist and my answer was
chorus I had a great chorus teacher
Suchet you who was a former Rockette and
she demanded professionalism of her
students and there we were in the chorus
just high school kids but she made us
warm up every time she told us how to
stand how to hold ourselves you know
wear lipstick girls because the lights
will wash you out she just gave us tips
and she expected us to be professionals
no Amateur Night in Dixie
and I took that lesson forward with me
into whatever I was doing whatever I was
going into whether it was going to be
chorus or history or astronomy or
whatever do it right
be a professional don't just do a you
know a half-baked job do everything
correctly
get down learn the details of what
you're going to do that was by far the
most important course for me chorus it
also taught me munication skills and for
scientists nowadays communication skills
whether they are writing skills or oral
speaking skills are incredibly important
so when kids ask me what classes do I
need to take I say well look you got you
had to take math because you got to
learn the language and you also have to
take communication classes whether it's
an English class or you know your music
classes band classes to teach you how to
cooperate in groups you know you don't
focus on physics you make sure you
broaden yourself and have a good solid
background in many different things
that's what you need to be a good
scientist the science teachers don't
like it when I say that they think you
know you take chemistry biology but like
yeah you do need to do those things but
that can come later your foundation
has to be in basic communication and the
basic language skills and I include math
as level language skills physics is a
very interesting field because you can
come at it from many different angles
when I was in college I didn't like
physics a lot and I really wasn't very
good at physics and there were a lot of
people around me who were really good at
physics
it means scary good at physics and they
weren't much help to me because I'd say
how do you do this and say well it's
just the answers obvious and I would sit
there going not to me so I chose not to
major in physics a lot of astronomers
and astrophysicists astrophysicists has
the word physics right in there do major
in physics I chose instead to major in
earth and planetary science and so my
background was in courses like geology
geophysics atmospheric chemistry but
again a lot of math courses and basic
physics courses things like the
Newtonian physics all the way through
quantum physics I did take those courses
I wasn't good at them but I passed them
I learned them enough to pass a C is a
passing grade is what I learned in
college and something that I tell young
people nowadays a lot C is a passing
grade you don't need straight age to be
a scientist
despite
you